just to editorialize a little bit before
I get started I want to let you know
that this is more of a message than a
substance talk this is more of a medley
talk than diving deep into one
particular topic I know some people like
one style some people like the other
style it's like when you go to your
friend's house and they say I'm a real
big Beatles fan and you look at the
record collection and all they have is
billboard top hits 1963 you say you're
not a fan of The Beatles yours the fan
of popular music this is one of those
stocks I I that analogy probably made no
sense to any of you don't worry the rest
of the talk it doesn't get any better
from this so let's get started this is
don't live packs your C Python
interpreter i'm james powell we're at PI
data chicago in saturday august 27th
2016 so one thing that you might have
seen on the title slide is my twitter
handle is don't use this code so if you
want you can follow me on twitter at
don't use this code that's also my email
address james at don't use this code
calm and you might wonder why do you
choose that twitter handle and there's a
very specific reason for that I like to
play with code I like to play with ideas
and if you ever been into the pound
Python channel on IRC there's a lot of
really mean people there are a lot of
jerks who every time you give some
advice to somebody they'll shout you
down so if some newbie comes in and says
can you do such and such and Python and
you say well you can but you shouldn't
they'll say no don't even tell them that
just tell them this pre described list
of explicit things you should do they're
the kind of people who ask whenever you
have a question why do you want to do
that because I don't want to just answer
the question directly legitimately so I
thought if I call myself don't use this
code then I can sidestep some of these I
can show people some neat stuff but
there's always this built-in disclaimer
that you shouldn't really do this this
is for fun or for education or for
exploration I want to show you a couple
of examples of some of these things so
some don't use this code examples for
exploration and these are all just
hopefully these pull up really quickly
oh there we go so one thing this is just
something I did for exploration somebody
asked oh can I do auto initialization of
instance variables of member variables
in Python I said well you could you
probably shouldn't it's not a pythonic
way but if you wanted to you could use
annotation to do this so you can see
this class uses annotations
says that X is default value is X plus y
wise default value is y plus 10y times
10 and you have a really small little
metaclass it's five lines long that
allows you to do this sometimes these
things are just to be cute so you know
there's this weird relationship between
things like mappings and dictionaries
and things like functions and I thought
well isn't memorization just kind of
looking something up my dictionary so
this is my ideal memorizing decorator
it's basically a subclass the dict
operator that implements missing and I
thought this is a really cool
combination of a bunch of small little
topics that you might come you might run
into when you start thinking very deeply
about what it means to memorize a
function and there's one really neat
feature of this which is it memorizes
independent of the signature so
independent of whether you pass
something as args or quarks it uses the
signature module or rather the signature
function in the expect module in order
to abstract over the different possible
ways of the function could be called
sometimes these might even be useful so
somebody said I have a big production
system and I needed to rename some of my
modules what should i do what's the best
practice so I said you know there's this
feature in Python called import hogs and
with about 30 40 lines of code you could
write an import hook so that when
somebody tries to import a module called
in this example moth it read it actually
imports the imaginal called math so you
could take a large system and you could
say this module is renamed to this and
you could even with so little code you
can even set up things like depth
warning dates and exception date so if
you try and import a module under its
old name after a certain date you get a
warning after a certain date you get an
exception and I said you know this could
actually be useful in it's a fairly well
understood example import hooks are a
pretty robust mechanism there's not a
lot of risk and using them so this is
something that you could actually do in
production to accomplish a real task
using some advanced feature python
sometimes these things are completely
and utterly bizarre so a friend of mine
had a problem and it's too complex to
really say what it was but basically the
solution that gave him was can you write
a metaclass that swaps the order of
derivation so you have a base class and
a derived class can you create a
metaclass so the derived class is
actually the base class and the base
class is actually derived class
so in this example here you have a
metaclass where here's some library code
that you write and the user subclasses
that library code and the user thinks
that they're the one who's the ultimate
derived class but in fact the metaclass
swaps the order of derivation so the
library has the ability to enforce
constraints on user derived code and
there was an actual real reason that you
want to do this but this is so utterly
bizarre that I don't even know if this
would really work I know in this
particular example it does but I can see
half of you have no idea why you'd even
want to do this I can't even remember
exactly the reason but i think it was
related to wrappings of pdb so we're
getting a little bit weird sometimes I
come up with these things in order to
prove somebody wrong which is never a
good reason to do something a long time
ago somebody somebody made a certain in
a talk that just rubbed me the wrong way
about whether you could compile Python
and it put me on an 18-month quest to
show different ways that you could have
bed Python into each other this is pi/3
so2 this is there's no c code here
there's only c FF five calls this is a
hundred line Python script that starts a
Python 3 interpreter starts a Python 2
interpreter within the Python 3
interpreter and starts a Python one
interpreter within the Python to
interpret within the Python 3
interpreter so they're all in the same
memory space but completely separate
from each other so all three of them can
import see libraries but they don't
sharing at that global state they're all
running in parallel there's no there's
no process boundary between them why you
might want to do this I have no idea but
it did prove that person wrong so I
mission accomplished there sometimes
these things are just about pushing the
boundaries so you know everybody likes
to talk about explicit self and some
people complain about him explicit self
so I thought let's push the boundaries
of good taste and see if we could do
implicit self so here's a little example
of these two classes that no longer take
an explicit South variable they have an
underscore self variable that's
implicitly created what I did was I live
patch to see Python interpreter using C
types to make the closure mutable and
then I inject into the closure the self
variable and I do a little bit of
bytecode Patrick so this is kind of
beginning to push the boundaries of
what's possible in terms of mucking
around with the C Python interpreter and
also pushing the boundaries of good
taste
I gave a talk earlier this year kind of
about dadaism at PI data Amsterdam and
you can see one of the tenants of that
ISM is really testing the boundaries of
what is socially acceptable and
sometimes these things are just utterly
and completely atrocious so I wanted to
show you an example of one of the worst
things I've ever done this thing was so
bad that it actually made me bored with
hacking the C Python interpreter because
I thought I can never top this so I want
to spend one or two minutes to just show
you this example this is all just a
prelude to my main point so I created a
pip installable module called our watch
some of you who are users of gdp know
you can add read watches in gdb I
thought could you add read watches in
Python could you create a mechanism in
Python so that every time somebody looks
at a variable not use it but just looks
at it it calls a hook and it turns out
you can and i want to show you what you
can do with it and then i'll show you
how it works and then we'll talk about
why you should never do it and some
qualifications on that so what you have
is a module that you can pip install now
I usually don't pip install it during
these talks just because if the internet
is wrong you know it could throw
everything off the rails but trust me if
you have a Python 350 and only a Python
350 interpreter you can pip install this
mechanism and you'll be shocked at what
it can do in your code you import our
watch and then what it does is it adds
two things the cyst module set our watch
and get our watch set our what sets read
watches get our watch shows you what
we'd watches you have what is a read
watch it's just a function like this
this function says I saw some frame I
saw some object at some frame here I
create an object just the number 10
assigned to the name X and every time I
look at that variable it triggers that
callback so I'm going to cut and paste
this code into an interpreter i'm going
to show you what working so here I have
the X variable it called my callback I
say X plus 2 it called my callback i put
x into a function it called my callback
twice once on the way in and once in the
function itself so every time that
variable has looked at not that dotted
access to it not anything every time
somebody looks at that it calls my
callback and the interesting thing is
what could you do with this obviously
there's some debugging purposes
it's the initial motivation can you
create a call back so that every time
somebody looks at a variable you you
know and I thought for a very big data
pipeline sometimes you have a million
data items and one of them is just
throwing things throwing a wrench into
things so maybe you could just see you
know one is this data item looked at
where in the pipeline is it is it
getting mutated in some undesirable
fashion it turns out you do some really
interesting things because it's in the
call back if you just raise the runtime
error then you have basic sandboxing so
in my Python interpreter here if I paste
this code here I can never access this X
variable because every time the callback
is called it raises the runtime error so
i have very basic sandboxing pretty neat
turns out you can do even worse things
here you can think that if I have the
ability to do something every time a
variable is called and I can return my
own thing I can do very basic promise
lazy mechanisms so here every time the
object is looked at it calls a method in
this case the method just sleeps for one
second so I'll show you that example
usually I have enough time to type these
out so i apologize going a little bit
quickly every time I look at X
behind-the-scenes it calls a function
and it returned some particular value
for that so notice it takes one second
to look at X because behind the scenes
is doing some long-running function in
this case it's just asleep so you could
think a lot of future mechanisms a lot
of promise mechanisms are some ugly
syntax on top of I do some action I let
it sit there but when I need to look at
it I then invoke the time that is
required in order to actually perform
that action you could also implement
pointers in Python so you could think
what is a pointer but a mechanism for in
direction and what is this but a
mechanism for in direction so in this
example let's restart this here I have a
variable X and it's number one two three
four I have a function X underscore that
repoint X at another variable so I now
point it at Z now X is 4 5 6 7 this is a
value type and I can point it around so
now i can add simple pointers in python
without these weird cell mechanisms that
people end up having to use using lists
with one element or whatnot and the
final thing that i can do is i can ruin
your day so i'll show you my
favorite example and I'll take a little
bit of time to look to go through this
in my callback instead of returning the
object that return the object times two
if that object is integer so now 1 is to
2 is for one plus one is for two times
two is eight I could really ruin your
day how about that so you can see what
the mech it is like this is absolutely
and completely atrocious why on earth
would you want to do it well there's
some reasons for debugging purposes or
you might want to do something like this
but before I get into why or if you'd
want to do this let me tell you how I
did it because when you see how I did it
it'll shock you a little bit further
this is just you know this is the source
code for it's a pip installable module
so this is the directory where the
source code is and you can see there's a
sea component so see module and of
course it's a sea module because it's
patching some parts of the Python
interpreter namely it's adding things to
the cysts module so if we look at our
watches see we can see here is to get
our watch and there's the set or watch a
little bit above there's nothing that
interesting in here it's just setting
some particular state on the thread and
it just injects these things in the
sisal that's not a fairly unusual thing
for a python module to do but it's not
impossible for a python module to patch
existing see modules it does something
very interesting in the initializer
which is it calls this thing called hook
function and it calls hook function on
PI eval eval frame X hook function is a
little toy that I wrote a while back
which finds a publicly addressable c
function and assembly smashes it so it
jumps to another function that you have
pi eval frame X in the C Python
interpreter is the main interpreter loop
so what I'm doing is in my hip
installable importable module at live at
run time with no you no need to modify
binary on disk I find the main Python
evaluation loop I put a little assembly
trampoline and I trampoline to my own
version of it and in my own version of
it I can do pretty much whatever and
that's how I implemented our watch and
so one thing you can see in this is
there's two subdirectories in this for
Python 3 5 4 3 for 3 and Python 350 I'm
assembly patching the main interpreter
for Python so it's very specific to the
Python version or watch only works on
those two versions it could very easily
be patched to work on any 35 subversion
but I'm just too lazy to do that and
nobody really wants to use this in
production anyway but the reason for
that is very tiny otherwise
inconsequential non API breaking changes
to see Python source code break our
watch because it's such a weird
mechanism you know swapping out the
interpreter loop I want to show you what
the interpretive loop does to swap it
out just to drive this rather so here is
C eval see this is the main interpreter
loop for Python so if we search in this
file for a for loop somewhere in here
we'll see this this is the actual main
interpret loop for Python and you can
see if you scroll down these are all the
Python bytecodes load cons for loading a
constant you know binary multiplies
below rot 24 when you have XY equals y X
rotation of the variables on the stack
all I did and this is a diff view is
every time a variable is pushed or
popped to the top of the Python stack I
just call my callback that's it so you
can think that every time some variable
hits the python internal vm stack you
have the ability to call a callback and
suddenly you have the ability to add all
these amazing indirection mechanisms to
really fundamentally change the way that
the language of the interpreter works
and you can pip install it because you
don't have to patch the interpreter this
works on mac and windows there's nothing
more than a c compiler that's needed to
actually install the module if I created
a wheel you wouldn't even need a C
compiler at all you just have the dot s
0 on disk and it would just work now
that's meant to shocked and appalled you
and I actually presented this earlier
this year at Syfy I presented this plus
a couple of other things that I did with
the C Python interpreter I added
abstract syntax tree literals i added a
type of eager evaluation of python and
the point of that talk was to show what
is possible to do and then discuss why
you might or might not want to fork the
C Python interpreter for this talk I
wanted to take this somewhere different
because one question that I get often is
what do you do for work you know you
know me from the keynote
I came and talked about numb focused I
don't work for numb focus I'm a
consultant I writes code for money for
people who need code written and how
many of you having seen even one of
these atrocious things ever want me
anywhere near any of your production
code not a single not a single hand is
raised so clearly i want to show this to
you to show you what's possible but i
don't want to tell i want to tell you
that there's no way I'd ever do this in
production because you know I'm a
consultant i want your money i want you
to pay me money to write code and i want
to tell you that I'd never write this
kind of code for production because it
would terrify it would scare the living
daylights out of the next engineer who
comes along to look at it and so in that
talk I said you shouldn't do this you
should never do this and there was a
little joke in that talk where at the
beginning I explained that don't use
this code thing and at the very end I
said so should you ever do this and the
answer is no don't use this code but I
wanted to get into the reasons behind
this and some of the judgment and some
of the thinking behind this and go a
little bit deeper than what I did in
that talk because it's not just that I
want to have friends it's not just that
I want you to use my code in production
it's not just that I want you know to
get business and to convince you that
these techniques are possible and these
techniques give you some ability to
think about problems a little bit deeper
but you never actually do any one of
these with maybe the exception of like
the memo eyes thing in any production
code and even then you might have to
really sit down and think is this
something that I care about or do I care
more about solving some business use
case then writing some crazy code that's
completely self indulgent however
something very interesting thing is
something very interesting happen a few
days ago our keynote speaker from for
tomorrow David Beasley or one of our
keynote speakers for tomorrow David
Beasley tweeted this he said instead of
installing packages I think I'm going to
start a new movement of simply modding
the Python interpreter itself and
immediately Tom Caswell one of the
matplotlib developers said don't use
this code is already working on this and
then arum you are one of the simple apur
responded Hey look at this talk and it
started a somewhat short Twitter
discussion about why you'd ever want to
do this and I said no please Dave
Beasley don't do this it's a bad idea
and I didn't get permission to name this
talk Dave Beasley is wrong don't lie
Patrick C Python interpreter
so I have to cut that part out but I
wanted to show you some judgment or some
reasoning behind why this is something
you never really want to do because I
could tell you some legit problems and
some legit nitpicks with this approach I
I could tell you that it's completely
bizarre you look at this you have no
idea what to make of it this is
something that nobody else is doing just
because it's such a ridiculous thing to
do I could tell you very practically
there's no window support for this
mechanism I can live patch se Python
interpreter on linux on OSX oh and by
the way don't think that memory
protection on Linux means anything if
you have a proc file system you can
write through the proc file system if
the page is marked as read only doesn't
matter you right through the proc file
system it's always read right I don't
know if it's the same case on OSX but I
wouldn't be surprised if it is
unfortunately windows is a completely
different beast this doesn't work on
Windows Windows actually has its own
mechanism as I understand called detours
that allows you to do this kind of live
patching in a safe way and and
apparently that's used for things like
hot patching of the windows kernel when
you have updates on machines that can't
be rebooted I could tell you that
there's a legit problem that I have to
have these perversion and not per major
version I have to have / minor version
patches of the C Python interpreter
actually make this work and that's a lot
of maintenance burden I have to have one
version of this for every 3.5 dotted
release from there it's not an enormous
amount of work that change is only 50 to
60 lines long but I'd still have to
maintain in a lot of different places
and it's very rare for somebody to say
oh this module works but only in Python
350 from last Tuesday anything else and
it breaks that's a very rare thing to
happen I could tell you that you know
there's no pipe I support for this
mechanism and it's a very much a C
Python mechanism it only works in cases
where you have literally see Python not
just python that uses a stack-based
virtual machine just see Python only but
of course you could just tell me that
nobody uses pi PI and we'd move on to
the next slide it doesn't work with Seco
there's some weird corner cases for this
certain literal syntax just kind of
falls through clearly I can't capture
which look at variables in the sea layer
so inside methods for objects that are
implemented in C and Python like the
dictionary object I can't see if
something's being done in that
dictionary like if a key is being set or
if a value is being retrieved until it
reaches the level of the C Python main
interpret the bytecode area so it can
only capture read watches on things
which include byte codes so there's a
lot of area within many very commonly
used C modules like for example numpy
where the read watch just doesn't work
and one problem with this is it makes it
a very obtuse thing to explain to people
because I could tell you I can adry
watches to Python in these very limited
circumstances if you understand how C
Python as an interpreter works that's
not a case that I'm going to make and
you might say well this is great I might
use it for a million things and then
suddenly one of these little corner
cases pops up oh my code is passing
through numpy or its passing through
some module that somebody wrote insights
on and suddenly the read watch fails to
work and it's completely inexplicable
why it fails to work and some mechanism
of you built on top of that's an
important fails to work so it makes it
very obscure and I can tell you there's
some unpredictable behavior associated
with that because when we start to take
into account cases where you know you
could pass through site on generated you
know python generated via site on or
rather see code generated via site on
then we could have some weird
unpredictable behavior if you built a
mechanism like the promises or something
less on top of it but I want to give you
a better reason why you shouldn't do
this and I want to say it's a matter of
judgment and to really press upon you
white a matter of judgment comes down to
something that I saw a couple of days
ago when I was just reading of various
blogs somebody said yeah we're not
really impressed with docker supports
we've had a lot we've seen a lot of
point releases of docker that were
unstable so my company runs a custom
docker some of us are terrified to run
our own custom image much less a custom
docker and i thought this company has
full confidence the ability to run you
know custom self patched code that's
part of their infrastructure and i
imagine most of the audience if I told
you there's one or two bugs in numpy go
patch them you're
off and use that in production it's
completely out of the realm of what is
feasible for what you for what you're
the tolerance for that level of
technical sophistication however that's
not true for everyone so I want to give
you a couple of examples of that I love
make and I love make files and I use
make and make files in many places where
they're not well suited and sometimes
I'm working on a project and I need to
either share that project with the
organization that's paying for that
project or I'm bringing other people on
to that project to collaborate with me
and I have to have that very
uncomfortable discussion which is here's
the crazy way that I do things can you
please follow all of these indulgences
and all these crazy things and one of
them is I really like make and a lot of
you will say make us a horrible tool
never use make you know don't even use
shell scripting but i feel that make has
never really know that I know their
specific limitations there's cases where
I wouldn't use it but I feel comfortable
in the places where I do use it or meta
classes a long time ago I saw a talk
called don't use meta classes and I
thought this is a garbage talk because
clearly meta classes give you a very
specific mechanism that up until very
recently there's no other way to
specifically do that namely meta classes
in a sound bite are one of the only ways
you can originally enforce a constraint
from a base class to a derived class
there are many ways to enforce
constraints from derived class at the
base classes but the other way around
metaclass is really the only mechanism
do that so to tell somebody don't don't
write meta classes is to tell them
here's something that you need to be
able to do sometimes don't do that just
find some other more convoluted way to
do it in some cases meta classes are a
very short and very concise way to do
something and they can be pretty
predictable that said for the swap meta
example where I swap the order of
derivation I have no idea if that
actually works outside of limited
example that's something where we're
touching the boundaries of human
knowledge I don't think I understand I
don't think I understand how the type
mechanism in C Python works well enough
to tell you that this is actually safe
to do and even your own demo code
similarly oh by the way PS Python 36 ads
in its sub class which is a safe way to
use meta classes and there's a lot of
complaints about meta classes I would
use a metaclass in any case where it's
library code that somebody's not going
to derive from and there's no multiple
Herenton
veriton big burden because sometimes
metaclass the multiple inheritance give
you all sorts of crazy you they break
the model in some ways in its subclasses
Python three sixes approach to solve
that but I can tell you in short there's
some legitimate cases there's some
legitimate places where you might use a
metaclass and some illegitimate places
one thing that you might have peaked at
when I was running my Python interpreter
was I run my Python interpreter using
this tool called BAMF which is short for
better virtual em I don't like virtual
em that's that's how I start projects
when somebody's gonna join us say you
know I don't use virtual em because I
don't like it and I gauge from the look
in their eye whether they think I'm
crazy or not and it sounds absurd you
don't like virtual em so you wrote your
own that's it's absolutely ludicrous but
if you look at them it's just a shell
script that's about 50 lines long and
it's very well understandable and if you
don't like using them you can still go
back and use virtual em but I don't like
bridge lamp so there's a there's a place
where that judgment some people agree
and some people don't or custom kernels
I run a custom kernel on my laptop and
when I say that you're all getting a
thought in your mind oh he's one of
those guys but the reason for that is I
happen to buy a laptop that didn't have
very good hardware support for one of
the pieces of hardware that was
configured with I run a distribution
we're installing custom kernel was
literally a single command line pack aur
dash S and the name of the colonel
there's no updating it's just as easy as
app get I run a custom kernel but some
of you would think custom kernels oh my
goodness it's a it's the extremes of
what somebody might want to do somebody
came to me with a desire to pay a lot of
money for a fork C Python that they
wanted to use internally at their
organization they didn't want to use the
C Python that's available python.org
they wanted a forked and use themselves
what except if you look at a lot of big
companies Google has our own internal
fork C Python if you go to Pike on and
you go to their booth then you listen to
their talks they talk about it all the
time YouTube or a brother YouTube has
their own Fork C Python where they added
a bunch of stuff to it a lot of these
really big companies which have the
ability to support something as
ridiculous as a fork C Python happen I
wouldn't be surprised if the company
that came to me willing to pay me this
money is the last of the come
of that size to actually get on the
bandwagon of forking C Python so for for
something that you consider to be the
most outrageous of all of my examples is
par for course for companies of a
certain size with a certain tolerance
for technical sophistication so when I
thought about this I came back to
something that I a coat that i had an
earlier an earlier presentation that i
gave couple years back and the question
was what's the difference between good
coding bad code I'm sure all of you know
the answer good code is code I wrote bad
code is code you wrote it's the same
thing with technical judgment good
judgment is my judgment bad book
judgment is your judgment so they're a
bunch of you sitting in the audience
right now and I've given you all of my
you know equivocating all of my
qualifications for why sometimes these
things are useful and you're like this
guy is nuts his judgments horrible and
then probably in about a week or two
time you're going to do something where
other people in the room would disagree
with you and you'd say but you know what
about the extenuating circumstances
that's how it works so what I thought in
this talk that I would do to try and
answer this question as truthfully as
possible is to discuss with you some
ways that this judgment can be guided
because it's clear that there are some
very weird and wild things you can do if
you submit yourself to the gods of
technical sophistication if you're
willing to do whatever is crazy
whatever's theoretically possible and
you have no qualms and no and you have I
don't want to go further than saying you
have no qualms but if you have no
inhibition to submit yourself to just
whatever you get what you ever you can
do if you never think well I can do it
but should I that never comes up this
judgment can be guided it can't be
systematized I can't tell you strictly
why a forked colonel is good in some
cases or wife or python makes sense for
this company but not that company and I
can give you a couple of questions that
I ask myself when somebody comes to me
and says I'm gonna pay you money to do
something and if it breaks your butts on
the line and I say oh I want to do the
simplest thing possible because I don't
want it to break and because I want to I
live in New York City so I kind of want
to live a nice life right one of the
questions I ask myself is is this a
model or a mechanism in many of the
cases here what I've done like
classes are usually a mechanism they
don't add a model they don't add the
overhead of this is a new abstraction
you have to learn it's just a mechanism
to accomplish a task and in many cases
when you look at things you can say
there's a way to accomplish this task
with a mechanism that uses subclassing
or uses m4 or uses macros or something
like this and it's 100 lines long and
there's a mechanism that's ten lines
long and you might say well all i'm
doing is implementing this mechanism i
might as well use the shorter version if
that matters to me so sometimes there's
a big distinction in terms of the
application of technical judgment as to
whether you're creating a new model a
new abstraction you're fundamentally
changing the way you think about the
problem or you're just implementing some
mechanism that's used in the process of
solving the problem and you can think
about that for a lot of these things
been versus virtual m this is the
mechanism the mechanism is isolation of
Python interpreters so does it really
matter how you accomplish that as long
as you're not adding overheads that your
deployment team can't manage not really
if you're fundamentally changing the way
that Python modules work then that's
something different do you understand it
fully swamp meta I promise you it took
me a shot meadow was a young kid named
Joe Jeff Nick who has examples that are
even weirder and even wilder than mine
look them up on on github Kwazii quotes
is one of them where he embeds our code
into Python code he embed C code into
Python code and they can interact with
each other this kid is absolutely nuts
and I thought you're a young kid but you
know I still have some youth in me so
here's a problem that we're gonna try
and solve bring in a race to solve it so
we raced and it took me 24 minutes to
get the answer it took him 26 minutes to
get good answer and I thought not bad
for an old guy but I don't understand it
fully I don't really understand what
that mechanism does I kind of works for
the limited case of just proving
somebody that something could be done I
don't really understand it fully and in
many of these cases you might say well
do I really want to take the risk that
I've misunderstood what I've done in the
case of things like import hooks I can
tell you anybody who spends a couple of
hours with a documentation on import
hooks can understand how import hooks
fully dead stop so a lot of things that
you can do that are pretty neat with
Python and with large deployment
environments large production systems
that you can accomplish with import
hooks I would encourage you to do
because there's really not a big barrier
to understanding it fully and being able
to say at the end this rename hook thing
it actually works and it probably won't
ever break in ways that are in it'll
break in predictable ways it won't break
in some way that I'll just totally
blindside us one way to gauge that is
how precisely and how concisely can you
explain this so for example read watches
if I could make that work fully I could
have explained it very precisely it sexy
it's a call back anytime something's
looked at but one of the main problems
with it is I can't explain it precisely
or concisely because it's not really
that it's a call back where for whenever
a variable is looked at subject to the
following qualifications that it's only
if you're using C Python and if only if
it's a variable that that's popped to
the top of the Python stack or that's
pushed to the Python stack so forth and
so on this is this is where the problem
lies it's not there's a leakiness to
this abstraction one other one other
question I ask myself is how superficial
is this change so the use of something
like bem for virtualized is very
superficial you can swap it out very
easily you know some of these small
changes are very superficial but one of
the things that I showed at side pi was
the addition of new syntax to see Python
you could you could represent abstract
syntax trees and the reason for that is
you could do some nice api's like you
get an R in Python but it was not a
superficial change to change the
fundamentally changes the way that you
would write your code in the Python
language so to ask somebody to give them
that burden of learning my own
particular version of Python it's not
very superficial the person who's paying
me to do a fork C Python the changes
they wanted a fork C Python are actually
remarkably superficial so not changing
the language to add static typing
they're not change in language to make
it more like C++ to add curly braces
everywhere they're doing it for some
very small very superficial use cases to
accomplish very targeted goals but the
language for the most part will remain
completely unchanged and so somebody who
learns Python independently from
Coursera from EDX is going to come to
that organization to use their 40 Python
and they're not going to notice anything
that's that different for the YouTube C
Python you get into kind of the gray
area where may
be your forking of C Python adds things
to the language which people have to
learn about and you never want that to
be the case when you join an
organization they say you know we use
so-and-so popular open source project
but not really we have our own version
of it you never want that that's a huge
warning sign you never want that to
happen one really important
qualification is how perfectly do these
mechanisms work so some of these
mechanisms that I showed you the
beginning work more or less perfectly
they are complete but the the question
is really how perfectly how poorly does
it have to work read watches are
something that I actually do use and I
actually would use because in some
circumstances it doesn't actually have
to work perfectly I use them for
debugging so my production code runs a
stock C Python no changes to a
whatsoever but when i'm debugging
something and I want to figure out where
a bug is I use read watches and if it
breaks who cares I'm just debugging if
it works and it helps me find a bug I
fix the bug in the code but this the the
patch the Python interpreter is not what
i'm using a production so there's very
low bar in terms of how well this
mechanism has to work because it's used
in a very limited circumstance i have
considered using read watches for things
like documentation generation where at
PI data berlin this year i gave a talk
called korg where I said you know we
have these api's in pandas a map plot
lib and you look at the help text for
that you look at the doc string for it
and it has star arcs and star star wars
you can't tell what what variable names
it takes you could use read watches in
order to figure out what variable names
it takes by running through the gallery
of all the sample code and seeing at
which function the various arguments you
pass in are actually looked at and you
could build a graph of you know Matt
plot lib calls this helper calls this
helper calls this helper calls this
helper and these are the variables that
are used at each level and you could
supplement the documentation and the end
product would be better documentation
and so if the mechanism didn't work
perfectly the documentation might be
slightly missing something you might
people say this takes star arcs and star
star quarks and we know that the star
star quarks includes these things but
may include other things no that's not a
very big bird it's not a very big
barrier one other important
what's the scope of the effect how big
is it what kind of burden are you
putting on the next person in order to
accommodate your technical
sophistication because i will tell you
here and now we are all guilty of / of
indulging ourselves with technical
sophistication of wanting to do
something that's cool and writing code
that's more cool and more fun than it is
actually useful and sometimes we snap to
our senses after two or three
all-nighters you know making something
work and we say great i made it work but
we just just give it to the intern and
just having to spend the summer you know
doing it by hand doing it the dumb old
manual way or you know oh i got my
little module to work but let's just pip
install the one that's crappier that
because that's what people now right
what's the scope what's the burden
you're putting on the people around you
how big of the change is it how much
does somebody have to learn or
understand before they can actually
enter your now distorted world and then
I think the last question is what if
you're wrong what if you've employed
some technical sophistication and you
thought you did it right but you didn't
what if you miss something what does
that mean can you risk that and the
answer is in most cases you can't so
when I'm writing code for people they're
paying me money I can't risk it if it's
wrong it's my reputation that's my
business that's on the line I can't show
i can't give you something that's you
know totally crazy that solves your
problem very easily but then breaks and
takes your business down I wouldn't stay
in business so oftentimes I stop myself
I ever I don't do these things because I
say even if there's a one-percent chance
of me being wrong that's to greater risk
one of the biggest markers for why
people employ technical sophistication
is their appetite their budget their
risk tolerance for technical
sophistication and so oftentimes when
you look at the actual code that I write
for actual money it's very simple very
basic code I use standard standard
libraries I don't relieve you know I
don't do things super tersely I don't do
i do things in a pythonic or Eddie
ematic fashion but I do them in a way
where if somebody comes to me and says
we paid you all this money and that's
what you wrote I say well I don't want
to I don't have that conversation and
none of you to and that's one of the
main things for me what if I'm wrong
however if I'm doing something for fun
I'll bet sir
so with that said I hope I've given you
a couple of reasons why you should live
patch your interpreter obviously there
are some cases where if you apply this
judgment it makes sense if you don't
care if you're wrong if you're doing it
for fun if you're doing it for debugging
or documentation generation where the
deliverable is not the code that you're
writing but some artifact of the code if
you're doing some analysis for many of
you doing data analysis nobody cares how
you do that data analysis don't care if
you use Python used are use MATLAB they
care what the suggestions are the
recommendations that you're making based
on analysis are then in those cases you
can employ whatever sophistication you
desire as long as you get your job done
because if you're wrong about the
technical sophistication as long as
you're not wrong about the results
you're okay at the same time don't catch
a live interpreter because there are
many cases where this is going to
absolutely blow up in your face you can
add some amazing things to see Python
very easily but you probably don't want
to be the person who gets called at 3am
when they say your thing broke again so
I couldn't tell you strictly whether you
should or shouldn't pad Patrick Python
interpreter this is why I put a slash in
the name do or don't but try and think a
little bit deeper about the
justifications and the judgment that you
employ when you decide to use technical
sophistication because it is a very big
consideration and all of our work this
is don't live patcher C Python
interpreter I'm James pal thank you very
much oh and p.s there's a pep 523 that
allows you to do a lot of this stuff
safely it allows you to add I'll show
you the pep it allows you to add frame
evaluation API so you can patch see val
dot c in a.c module and it's done safely
and correctly and the reason they added
that was or the reason they're pushing
them for this it hasn't been accepted
yet but the reason this is being pushed
for is certain projects like the pigeon
[ __ ] for C Python want to be able to jet
Python coach they want to swap out the
sieve a loop that a normal see Python
interpreter uses for one that juts the
code it doesn't make a big difference
doesn't make any difference to somebody
who's just writing Python code they
won't see the difference other than the
code runs faster but you need to make
some fairly sophisticated low level
changes in order to
do the chillin so does that mean is
anybody can actually use any of this
stuff know who has it the rename hook so
one question I have for you since you
don't have any questions for me and I
still have five minutes your time and
ask you some questions have any of you
ever done something where a day later
you said that I didn't really do that to
solve the problem or to do what was best
for the person I'm working for I did
that just to play with something and
make myself happy I mean you ever done
that no you're lying all of you should
raise your hand everybody does that have
have you ever have you ever done that
and you put a lot of effort into it and
then you said now that I've actually
made it work let's never touch this
again or ever actually use it a couple
of you right have any of you ever gotten
into a very heated argument with one of
your co-workers as to whether something
was too crazy or wasn't crazy enough
where where they said you can't do it
this way and you said no there's this
circumstance of this circumstance have
you gone to that kind of argument a
couple of people how did you were you on
the side for doing it more sophisticated
or the psyche we're doing a less
affected who are on the side for doing
it more sophisticated who are on the
side for keep it simple stupid a bunch
of you when you're on the side for doing
it more sophisticated what kind of
things did you say you know it's okay
it's not that hard it's just code is
that what you said what kind of things
did you say how do you add you make your
case what kind of what how did you
employ your judgment what tools did you
use as a highly-paid individual to say
you know we're all professionals here
we're all adults here let's get it done
what do you do what do you say or people
on the other side just shut it up
so so does that mean that you avoid
using advanced features of Python
because people who don't know python the
hook so you can see that you're kind of
you you kind of wheel it back a little
bit just I'm not familiar i'm not very
familiar with I dev but maybe if we look
at that after the talk we can answer the
question this oh that happens one one
thing that I've had in many cases is I
was working in a company once and we had
this database and the database schema
that we had was what they call it n
tribute entity attribute value schema so
it didn't actually use the tables or any
the feature of the database and I looked
at then said we're just doing this so
they don't have to go to the DBA teams
and we can store arbitrary documents why
don't we use in no SQL database and the
person who is in charge of project
looked at me and said what nobody
actually uses those it was like aren't
you stupid like seriously have you ever
worked with somebody and you're like can
you please use version control and they
said well you better get that fancy
version control out of here we toured
things up and named them dash 1 dash one
final and my where I'm from you ever
been in that situation I have I have I
think a couple of you have been in that
situation you're like you know we should
use Python and they're like what do you
mean XL is not good enough bash
scripting isn't good enough what you can
see is that the technical sophistication
argument occurs at many levels in many
different micro macrocosm and so what
you think and you take to be par for the
course Oh use docker why not other
people look at and they say what do you
mean use docker why can't we just you
know
why can't we just have single processes
on machines and spend ten times as much
on resources have one server / service
that's an argument you have to make so I
hope you enjoyed that thank you very
much